قتل عده اشخاص اصيب اخرون في اطلاق نار
في مدينه تشيز كيك بولايه فرجينيا
الامريكيه وقالت الشرطه المحليه ان عدد
الاصابات غير معروف حتى الان وان منفذ
عمليه اطلاق النار من بين القتلى ونقلته
صحيفه واشنطن بوست عن متحدثه باسم المدينه
ان عدد القتلى
اقل من 10 اشخاص
سلمى هذا الاطلاق النار الذي حدث في
الساعه 10:15 مساءا وبقى الشرطه بالتوقيت
المحلي لمساء الثلاثاء الشرطه استجابت
لاتصال من المتجر حين وصلت كانت عمليه
اطلاق النار قد انتهت حيث وجدت الشرطه عده
اصابات وقتل
يعني ادله على وجود عمليات اطلاق النار
الشرطه تقول ان المنفذ من بين القتلى
ولكنها حتى الان همم ليس باستطاعتها تاكيد
عدد الاصابات والقتلى لان هذا المتجر هو
المتجر كبير جدا وعمليات التنشيط للتاكد
من انه لا يوجد اشخاص اخرين
في المكان تجري ولكن العمليه انتهت حين
وصول الشرطه وايضا المتحدث باسم الشرطه
ليه وكذانسكي يقول انه لا يعتقد بان
الشرطه اطلقت النار على المنفذ
وايضا يعني حتى هذه اللحظه لا يعلم ان كان
هذا المنفذ كيف قتل ولكن شبكه سي ان نقلت
عن مصادر قولها ان المحققون يعتقدون بان
منفذ هذه العمليه هو اما موظف او موظف
سابق في هذا المتجر وانه قام باطلاق النار
على موظفين اخرين في غرفه استراحه تابعه
للمتجر ايضا يعتقدون وفق سي ان ان وفق
مصادر نقلت عنها بان المنفذ هو من قتل
نفسه لذا حتى هذه اللحظه ما زال هناك
المزيد من المعلومات التي بانتظار ان
تكشفها الشرطه خصوصا فيما يتعلم للفيزي
عدد الضحايا ولكن العمليه انتهت معه وصول
الشرطه الى النساء